we're told to graph y is equal to
negative cosine of pi times x plus 1.5
in the interactive widget so pause this
video and think about how you would do
that and just to explain how this widget
works if you're trying to do it on khan
academy this dot right over here helps
to find the midline you can move that up
and down
and then this one right over here is a
neighboring extreme point so either a
minimum or a maximum point
so there's a couple of ways that we can
approach this first of all let's just
think about what would cosine of pi x
looks like look like and then we'll
think about what the negative does in
the plus 1.5 so cosine of pi x
when x is equal to zero
pi times zero is just going to be zero
cosine of zero is equal to one
and if we're just talking about cosine
of pi x that's going to be a maximum
point when you hit one just cosine of pi
x would oscillate between 1 and negative
1. and then what would its period be if
we're talking about cosine of pi x
well you might remember one way to think
about the period is to take 2 pi and
divide it by whatever the coefficient is
on the x right over here so 2 pi divided
by pi
would tell us that we have a period of 2
and so how do we construct a period of 2
here well that means that as we start
here at x equals 0 we're at 1 we want to
get back to that maximum point by the
time x is equal to 2. so let me see how
i can do that
if i were to squeeze it a little bit
that looks pretty good and the reason
why i worked on this midline point is i
liked having this maximum point at 1
when x is equal to 0 because we said
cosine of pi times 0 should be equal to
1. so that's why i'm just manipulating
this other point in order to set the
period right but this looks right we're
going from this maximum point we're
going all the way down and then back to
that maximum point and looks like our
period is indeed 2. so this is what the
graph of cosine of pi x would look like
now what about this negative sign
well the negative would essentially flip
it around so instead of whenever we're
equaling one we should be equal to
negative one and every every time we're
equal to negative one we should be equal
to one so what i could do is i could
just take that and then bring it down
here and there you have it i flipped it
around so this is the graph of y equals
negative cosine of pi x
and then last but not least we have this
plus 1.5 so that's just going to shift
everything up by 1.5 so i'm just going
to shift everything up by
shift it up by 1.5 and shift it up
by 1.5
and there you have it that is the graph
of negative cosine
pi x plus 1.5 and you can
you can validate that that's our midline
we're still oscillating one above and
one below the negative sign when cosine
of pi times zero that should be one but
then you take the negative that we get
to negative one you add 1.5 to that you
get to positive 0.5 and so this is all
looking quite good